[Applaudissements]
marie michelle houle et en direct sur le
8 la famille combal qui va arriver mais
pour lequel ce qu'on pense confrères
mais elle me met une village l'adorent
mais ce soir faut mettre lara fabian les
ché
[Applaudissements]
ça
je
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais on commence à parler que j'entends
par oi pas possible à l'hésitation
j'avais commandé des doses alors c'est
ça c'est ça
[Musique]
je te
à
un soldat
[Musique]
oui que se sert de baguette le genre de
huawei je suis devenu cascadeur c'est
deus dans les séries françaises il n'y a
pas de combat de près en saisir les gars
ils sont bataille qu'est ce qui se passe
sinon je suis fasciné par la taille à
monter descendre descend de monter te
casser la gueule
un show à l'américaine rythme sur la fin
[Applaudissements]
non
m
on aidera
quand on s'endort
j'y crois que tu peux fermer ta gueule
vous avez déjà connu l'amour parlons
bien je sais pas ce que vous avez eu un
coup de foudre en faisant un duo avec
quelqu'un par exemple sur je t'aime ça
m'est arrivé il ya une demi heure vous
dire merci la ramaz et on voit ça vous
est déjà arrivé ou pas non ça m'est
arrivé sur un plateau jamais faire un
pont d'or d'un duo sur un concert ou un
truc comme ça n'ont jamais non mettez
moi alors y en a une que j'adore à jouer
on n'est pas à l'état leur tête c'est
quand je ne chante pas
je sais
là
[Musique]
chanter tous de jeu
chante pas je ne chante pas une épouse
une mère une femme seins doit tout
savoir alors à quand je ne chante pas je
suis comme vous je suis comme ça
[Applaudissements]
ouais
quand je ne chante pas je regarde si ray
lane ou
[Applaudissements]